merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
j'ai souvenir hier soir lorsque nous
sommes quittés tôt ce matin il était un
peu plus d'une heure que le dérouleur
affiché 1037 amendement restant en
discussion
et par curiosité ce matin lorsque je me
suis réveillé je regardais où on était
le dérouleur nous étions à 1250
26 amendements avaient été déposé
pendant la nuit
et puis tout au fil de cette journée
vous avez des battu examiner voter un
nombre conséquent d'amendements mais
comme vous pouvez le constater le
dérouleur
continue d'augmenter
c'est une forme de vie sans fin nous
avons regardé
nous avons regardé
nous avons regardé les sous amendements
qui ont été déposés certains ont été
défendus d'autres ont été retirés
d'autres enfants étaient rejetés nous
avons eu des séries d'amendements de
sous amendements pardonnez-moi qui par
exemple lorsque une demande de rapport a
été formulée avec une date de remise au
1er avril 2024 les sous amendements 20
fois 30 fois proposé que plutôt que le
premier avril ça serait le 2 avril puis
le 3 avril puis le 4 avril puis le 5
avril nous avons eu il y a un instant
communication
des sous amendements monsieur le
Président que vous avez évoqué sur cette
amendement
sur cet amendement 21 32 de monsieur le
rapporteur il y en a je crois 150 ou 160
avec
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ils
se trouvent pardonnez-moi mais depuis
quelques jours je me perfectionne dans
le règlement du Sénat et il se trouve
que la parole du gouvernement est libre
et que je peux m'exprimer comme membre
du gouvernement un moment où je souhaite
sur les sujets qui intéressent le
gouvernement
il y a
160 amendements qui est font le tour du
Dictionnaire des produits chimiques et
des agents chimiques de France c'est une
volonté manifeste d'obstruction il n'y a
pas de volonté de débat il n'y a pas de
volonté de construction il y a une
volonté de blocage et ce blocage se
mesure par les chiffres nous en sommes à
5700 ou 5800 amendement déposés
exception faite désire recevabilité et
j'ai entendu mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs socialistes votre réflexion
disons ça sera une vie sans fin ça va
monter monter monter en réalité ce que
vous voulez c'est que le Sénat soit
privé de sa capacité à voter sur le
texte
vous voulez que
le Sénat se voit confisquer sa capacité
à délibérer et à le faire
démocratiquement et d'une certaine
manière mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vous opposez ce que vous
appelez la légitimité de la rue et la
légitimité du Parlement et nous croyons
à la légitimité du Parlement
un certain nombre
un certain nombre de présidents de
groupe un certain nombre de présidents
de groupe un certain nombre de Parlement
de sénateurs ont eu recours à
l'utilisation d'un certain nombre
d'articles du Règlement du Sénat et vous
êtes vous avez tous reconnu que si
l'opposition avait la possibilité
d'utiliser le règlement pour faire de
l'obstruction vous allez prononcé ces
mots
la majorité d'autres sénateurs pouvaient
avoir recours à règlement pour garantir
un bon déroulement du débat il se trouve
que le gouvernement peut aussi le faire
et donc en application l'article 44
alinéa 2 de la Constitution le
Gouvernement s'oppose à l'examen de
l'ensemble des sous amendements déposés
sur l'amendement 21 32 de monsieur le
rapporteur qui n'ont pas été soumis à
l'examen de la Commission
si
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
conformément à l'article 44 alinéa 2 de
la Constitution et l'article 46 bis
alinéa 4 du règlement
le gouvernement s'oppose à l'examen des
sous amendements à l'amendement 21-32
qui n'ont pas été antérieurement soumis
à la commission même la présidente de la
commission
confirmez-vous que l'ensemble de ces
sous amendements n'ont pas été soumis
antérieurement à la commission avant
l'ouverture du débat bien évidemment
monsieur le Président je confirme
puisque sésame c'est sous amendements ne
figurez pas dans avant l'ouverture du
débat donc n'ont pas été soumis à
l'examen de la Commission
merci madame la Présidente dans ces
conditions c'est sous amendement ne
peuvent être examinés
et donc je vais demander l'avis du
Gouvernement sur l'amendement 2132
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît mes
chers collègues la parole est à Monsieur
le Ministre merci monsieur le Président
un mot monsieur le Président pour dire
que le Gouvernement partage pleinement
partage pleinement la préoccupation de
la Commission sur la prévention du
risque chimique les obligations du Code
de travail qui prévoit la suppression
des expositions aux agents les plus
dangereux pour ceux pour d'autres la
limitation au minimum possible en
mettant neuf toutes les moyens de
protection disponibles sont notre
boussole en la matière et l'inspection
du travail en aspire le respect au
quotidien le quatrième plan santé au
travail qui renforce les actions de
prévention sur le terrain contre le
risque chimique et je rappelle que les
TPE peuvent bien les CARSAT obtenir des
aides financières pour cela les
conventions d'objectifs et de gestion la
branche à TP sont autant d'outils nous
mobilisons à la matière
il y a 22 000 substances enregistrées au
niveau européen avec des situations
d'exposition des normes d'expositions
maximum qui sont extrêmement variées et
de la pétrochimie au coiffeur en passant
par les employés de la propreté de
nombreux salariés français sont
potentiellement concernés le
gouvernement mais monsieur le rapporteur
le sait et extrêmement réservé sur
l'extension
du financement du fond d'investissement
dans la prévention l'usure
professionnelle à la question des agents
chimiques pourquoi cette réserve pour
deux raisons d'abord nous considérons
que la meilleure prévention en la
matière c'est de respecter les normes
limitant le niveau d'exposition et de
respecter les interdictions nous ne
sommes pas dans un champ de prévention
nous sommes dans un champ de sécurité la
deuxième prévention tient en fait que
aujourd'hui les employeurs ont une
obligation qui est celle d'assurer la
sécurité de leurs employés et dans ce
cadre doivent à la fois respecter les
normes d'exposition tout comme ils
doivent respecter les normes
d'interdiction lorsque les agents
chimiques sont particulièrement
dangereux
les mêmes employeurs ont une obligation
en matière d'équipement protectionnés
personnelles de sécurité
personnelle et collectif pour limiter
cela et le gouvernement ne souhaiterait
pas évidemment que le fipu puisse être
mobilisé pour financer des équipements
de protection individuelle qui relèvent
d'une obligation de protection des
employeurs aujourd'hui et il nous paraît
assez tenu de c'est difficile de définir
un champ relativement ténus nous le
pensons d'intervention du FIP puis en
matière d'usure professionnelle sur la
question des agents chimiques à part
peut-être la question de la formation au
titre de la prévention n'en aucun cas
les éléments de sécurité qui sont d'ores
et déjà à la charge des employeurs dans
le cadre de cette obligation c'est la
raison pour laquelle mais vous le savez
monsieur le rapporteur nous avions cette
réserve que c'est plutôt une demande de
retrait je sais que l'amendement était
adopté par la commission des affaires
sociales donc je fais valoir cette
position en ayant bien conscience que
une grande part se débat continuera dans
le cadre de la navette parlementaire
merci monsieur le ministre
[Musique]